China's Gobi Desert
a vast rugged landscape scoured by eons
of erosion here paleontologists are
uncovering fascinating new portals to a
dino Golden Age
[Music]
we targeted this area because it's a
really important time period right when
the dinosaurs started to radiate and
become big the scientists are astounded
by the breadth of their discoveries
several previously unknown species have
been unearthed including an intriguing
Raptor they named him guanlong meaning
crested dragon as the excavation
progresses another guanlong skeleton
emerges below the first and then others
below this if we look at the dinosaur
record from every continent on the
planet there is virtually nothing like
this they find several of these Dino
graves where multiple skeletons are
preserved one atop the other in columns
of depth evidence of some mysterious
prehistoric catastrophe this block that
I'm sitting next to shows a really
important piece of information a really
important piece of the puzzle the
skeleton shows signs of struggle broken
bones and contorted poses suggest that
these dinos were fighting for their
lives dr. David Ebert has a theory these
animals must have been struggling in the
mud there had to be some kind of
movement that churned the mud up an
analysis of fossilized soil samples show
volcanic ash present we know that
volcanoes were exploding from time to
time in this area
that these volcanoes were nearby because
some of the crystals are quite large and
they wouldn't be able to travel that far
in the air
dr. Ebert also finds evidence that
guanlong stomping grounds would have
included vast marshlands we're falling
ash met wading wetlands Dino death traps
were born the ash would have within it
lots of glass glass particles and those
glass particles would settle down into
this wetlands area creating a thick mud
a soupy mud viscous and unforgiving this
quick mud could be perilous to any
animal that happened upon it
predators sink potential prey helplessly
struggling against the mud would move
into a tack and then get stuck
themselves once the first animal got
trapped then they became active predator
traps
you